noi siamo
veloci
ciao eccoci qua
dentro vero cioè mi ha fatto venire un
erezione per quanto dichiara molto bene
infatti restiamo in tema proprio buy ok
allora nella puntata di prima la prima
puntata di feroci abbiamo avuto il
piacere di fare una meravigliosa
chiacchiera con nick cerioni stylist
delle star che ci ha permesso di
tracciare una linea preziosa tra
apparenza e d'espressione disse ad ogni
modo oggi vestite abbiamo deciso di
tailleur se li è scoprire quante cose si
possono fare così come mamma già fatti
stiamo per ospitare nome ginevra ok
professione content creator per adulti a
un canale all i fans un canale su
pornhub ha iniziato la sua attività
molto presto ma ha avuto da subito tante
soddisfazioni nel suo percorso
lavorativo ha fatto anche la carla la
madre del suo manager le ha regalato un
sex toy digitale che sono curioso di
capire di che cosa si tratti perché non
lo so ragazzi sapete che sono arrivati
un sacco di sex toy nel giro della mia
vita regalati sembrava un certo punto il
mio comodino la riserva coi minipimer
qualsiasi cosa io devo ammettere di
essere molto ignorante nell'ambito
sequestrate ma sarò felice di apprendere
perché tra i suoi minatori ci sono anche
uomini di chiesa
ecco
assolutamente non ci facciamo mancare
niente la sua attività è solamente sul
digitale non fa mai incontri ha una
laurea ormai in parafilie delle persone
facciamo entrare baby bunny 2000 allora
eccoci qui ginevra palme
bene tutto bene io parto subito a
bombazza con la prima domanda ok ok
quando siamo piccoli e non sappiamo
ancora cosa sia il senso di dare il mio
caso mi ricordo ancora che avevo tipo 12
anni quando mi disse una mia amica che è
un nostro compagno di scuola si stava
tipo masturbando al telefono con lei e
ad un certo punto ha sporcato il
pavimento e non capivo cosa
che cos'è che sapevi da piccola
praticamente niente perché inizialmente
giustamente in meno non mi parlavano di
ste cose no anche a scuola diciamo che
l'argomento non è molto
era esatto in generale soprattutto in
italia non è molto cioè 70 bubi è un
grande tabù quindi di conseguenza
diciamo che inizialmente non ne sapevo
nulla proprio zero facendo esperienze
penso che uno impari a fare determinate
cose comunque a conoscerle posso
chiederti quando è stata la prima volta
e come è stata soprattutto la mia prima
volta è stata tardissima in realtà
perché la mia prima volta è stata 17
anni
non è che è 20
20 20 è successo questo
che sei veramente un maestro di eleganza
lo sai e 17 anni come è stata correndo
la bruttissima raga brutti eravamo tutti
a tutti e due abbastanza piccolini
quindi di conseguenza non è stato bello
c'era prima volta spariamo sta cosa
della prima volta sarà bellissimo quasi
per nessuno lo è cioè io parlo con le
mie amiche con i miei amici tutti i miti
milioni non conosco nessuno che ha dei
bei racconti sulla prima volta che io no
notte la mia tremenda ma era quella di
forse ha dovuto chiedere perché scusa
soffrire già siamo a quei livelli sino
un disastro anche senza tutto chiedere
scusa ma nel senso che non era stata una
gara dove dopo una grande esibizione
ecco
ok ok quindi ginevra all'inizio uno più
della sua scoperta sessuale cos'era per
te il sesso ma inizialmente cioè io me
lo faccio raccontare delle altre mie
amiche che comunque avevano perso la
verginità prima di me ok e mi dicevano
ok la prima volta è normale che non è
bellissimo però poi vedrai che imparerai
a conoscere il tuo corpo e comunque a
capire cosa ti piace cosa non ti piace
quindi io stavo un attimo tipo dio sarà
veramente così figo per come me lo
raccontano loro sì adesso vediamo e
piano piano ci ho preso la mano
che ha detto una cosa bella cioè il
sesso e conoscere il proprio corpo in
quanto è vero c'è uno comunque quando si
parla di sesso è facile subito far
malizia battutaccia invece è proprio
comuque a un'indagine del proprio corpo
cosa bella io penso che per avere una
buona vita sessuale
devi essere in primis tu a darti piacere
per imparare a conoscere il proprio
corpo perché quando tu poi stai con un
partner al a letto dici ok questa è una
cosa che mi piace questa è una cosa che
non mi piace e io qui allora arrivò con
la domanda ok avresti mai pensato che
invece poi quella roba lì che per alcune
persone un tabù anzi per tante persone
un tabù poi in un certo senso sarebbe
diventata una roba non solo
importantissima nella tua vita ma
proprio anche un motivo di lavoro il
nostro specialmente no io ho trovato la
persona penso giustissima nel momento
giusto nel senso che avevamo una
complicità nel sesso fantastica ok
avevamo provato veramente di tutto ci
piaceva praticamente fare tutto insieme
ok al che abbiamo pensato cerchiamo di
fare qualcosa un pochino più
trasgressivo quindi andavamo in alcuni
siti ok dove facevamo campo e random
gratuite gente entrava e ci beccavano i
due che facevamo cose e la cosa ci dava
qui nel mio letto perché no poi durante
il lock down
io ho iniziato a fare la campbell stiamo
parlando ovviamente tu eri maggiorenni
comunque sì sì sì avevo allora ho
iniziato che ne avevo ricordiamo la
tutte le persone
di lavori bisogna farli si devono fare
sono messe la maggiore anche perché è
obbligatorio perché tutti i siti
richiedono documenti sono molto attenti
molto molto molto certi richiedono
verifiche su verifiche e ti chiedono i
documenti le foto le foto che tutto
prima di arrivare lì alla cam girl
quando tu avevi queste questi siti col
tuo compagno di allora che non so se
alla fine sisifo key anche lì c'era già
un'attività di lucro no quindi a
lavitola maniera completamente che
sperimento proprio ok esatto sì sì
sempre ok e la camgirl e invece è una
cosa che capita invece è stata una cosa
retribuita perché io ho lasciato il
lavoro perché la voce pregante faceva un
lavoro un po particolare ci aiuti le
pulivo i treni di notte
ok però durante lottavano tu capisci che
coal co vide tutto quanto io vivevo a
casa del mio fidanzato con i suoi
genitori e sua nonna di 93 anni o
fermate
loro sapevano tutto è dall'inizio loro
hanno sempre saputo tutto e come
l'accordo questa cosa no benissimo cioè
io ho un rapporto con i miei suoceri
manca cioè io con loro ho sempre parlato
di tutti è uscito l'argomento è come
uscito mi sentivo di tutto il giorno che
poi non glielo dici c'è il figlio stava
di sopra io stavo di sotto da sola 8 9
ore al giorno ok mi sentiva nel cablo
così tante ore o dio non nel senso sav
online 8 9 ore poi la gente entrava e
andava tipo minuto ok quindi durante la
quarantena altro ragazzo non c'era e
stava in stanza io stavo in stanza
facevo la cambiarla mentre lui
messaggiava con altre persone perché
avevamo preso tipo su altri siti
trovavamo persone che cercavano video
quindi vendevamo video a privati quindi
lui chi è complice in questa cosa non
tutto quando fa il suo lavoro
soprattutto in coppia deve esserci
fiducia al cento per cento perché se non
lo fai come
vv quindi il bigottismo ma guarda io
inizialmente l'avevo malissimo
psicologicamente mi uccideva perché
comunque io ho iniziato che ci avevo
diciannove di anni quindi era era
pesante capito cioè io mi ritrovavo
messaggi di uomini di 50 anni che mi
dicevano cose orrende quindi erano
bigotti nutrienti ma in realtà io dico
sempre che è più bigotti poi sotto sotto
fanno sempre lì e quindi di botti smo
vissuto male e ad oggi come trovi con
indifferenza con totale indifferenza
perché mi sono tutte le scatole di star
male per persone che per me non valgono
niente cioè onestamente parlando io sono
dell'opinione no vivi e lascia vivere io
faccio il mio lavoro non ti dò fastidio
o una società a pago le tasse anche per
questo la gente viene a rompere le palle
tutto invece il contesto delle amicizie
ci sono stati di supporto c'è stato un
allontanamento mi sono resa conto che
quando la voce si è sparsa tra spari di
tutti cioè perché era vergognoso girare
con una persona che faceva un
determinato lavoro che agli occhi della
società non è giusto e non è bello
quindi se livello di insicurezza
personale deve essere una cosa orribile
ci sia l'occasione di poter ribadire al
mondo io sono così vale la pena
coglierla perché è
depurarsi più che altro come si chiama
il tuo ragazzo one ok immagino che in
tutto questo era ginevra la [ __ ]
perché quasi è un gran figo tuttora c'è
tanto anche diciamo misoginia in questa
l'ipotesi mi lavoro versi assolutamente
cioè quando fa il lavoro del genere in
coppia lui africo perché giustamente lui
l'ex coppa russe che non ci avevo mai
pensato a questa strage ogni tanto devo
fare sforzi per capire qual è il livello
basso a cui si può arrivare c'è la
stessa cosa fatta da due persone diverse
però tu che sei donna certo viene
affidata incredibile aoki quindi anche
lui fa
anche lui fa
[Musica]
la puntata di
tutti no io ero rimasto che gestiva le
tue cose no io ho iniziato a girare
video con lui
sì però è gratuito poi magari pensavo
che lui avesse detto sto nel backstage
ci sta nel backstage
lavorando cioè solo la coppia artistica
fondamentale della storia difficile però
sparare lavoro e vita privata cioè nel
senso come ma in realtà no perché ci
siamo imposti dei limiti delle regole
del tipo dobbiamo girare con una ragazza
la ragazza viene a pranzo mangiamo
insieme vediamo se andiamo d'accordo
abbiamo un tot di scene da girare
giriamo quelle scene facciamo le foto
prepariamo tutto quanto è poi quella
ragazza se ne va sai che sono
affascinato dalla lucidità con cui parli
perché comunque c'è evidentemente anche
questa cosa di conoscere più il corpo ti
da un modo veramente di affrontare le
cose mentali che per me la gelosia per
le un limite cioè un freno a mano tirato
nella vita di tutti i giorni per me
stesso per assurdo la tua una storia
d'amore prima ancora che essere ne
assumano una storia di lavoro e ho
deciso di andar via di casa a testare
con lui il tuo rapporto col tuo corpo si
è sempre stato buono
no ma non lo è tuttora e poi tutti i
mostri siccome funzioni io penso che
bisogna avere la consapevolezza di
doversi a mare per come si è cioè io ci
sono delle cose che non mi piacciono di
meno ma mi mostro perché nonostante
magari quelle cose che mi rendono un po
no timida però insicura ok so che quelle
cose sono mie
se fanno parte di me le posso cambiare
se voglio le cambio se non voglio
ritengo così cioè
non bisogna far vedere solo le cose
belle no facile mostrarsi quando si è
perfetti nessuno è perfetto alla fine
allora li fa anzi io non l'ho mai avuto
però c'è dato col lavoro si ci sta che
non abbiate ne voglio si ok abbiamo
iniziato a girare dei video quando
magari uno dei due non aveva voglia
abbiamo detto ok no senti lasciamo verde
lo rifacciamo poi arriva un momento
ancora tutti ci ragazzi chiede pietà
letteralmente chiede che tale che male
c'è basta una certa bar certo quindi sì
io finivo lui magari c'è la voglia
perché giustamente stava lì e mi
guardava avute capito ed io non ce la
facevo parlavamo prima di richieste
strane o da che vengono da persone
strane queste richieste strane e che
cioè capita che vengano sempre mosse con
rispetto ci aiuti potrei dire guarda mi
eccita che tool e chi le ali di questo
cane però te lo sto chiedendo con
rispetto cristo è
però ci sta che uno comunque ti chieda
una cosa stravagante però con rispetto e
tu sei libero di dire di no c'è anche
tanta mancanza di rispetto la maggior
parte di quelli che mancano di rispetto
su quelli più grandi tipo sui 60 65
io avevo clienti sul sito di cambiarle
che arrivavano anche a 75 addirittura
qual è la cosa più strana che ti hanno
chiesto c'era uno che si eccitava a
vedere le ragazze che prendeva
accoltella dei cuscini
sì mi sono perso il secondo set
di un cuscino
è una ragazza che si eccitava vedere le
ragazze a un ragazzo che voleva vedere
le ragazze pugnalare un cuscino se io ho
detto guardano un posto staccata di mia
suocera
non me la sento onestamente io del tuo
identikit ho letto una cosa
veramente persone di chiesa anche se ed
eri sicura che fossero di chiesa si si
si cosa cerca
era quello di cuscini
no questo era anche poi anche peggio
cioè il tipo mi mandava i video tipo
all'una di notte che si infilava le e
in luoghi nei luoghi e poi ballava nudo
con il crocifisso quello grosso
face tipo la spara quindi proprio
blasfemia e di brutto ricordiamo sempre
che ci deve essere rispetto io tante
volte mi sono la base esatto io tante
volte mi sono dovuta per ritrovare in
situazioni veramente
rende perché non c'era rispetto
dall'altra parte poi sono abbastanza che
s'agita facilmente me la prendo male e
stiamo parlando comunque di un lavoro
che tu svolge online
tu non hai mai fatto incontri in cui
diciamo gli incontri che fai solo quella
che fanno contro con persone che fanno
il mio stesso lavoro
ne conosco tanti con cui non ho neanche
lavorato ma è bello ritrovarsi insieme
per parlare
metterci un po confronto no per tante
cose è bello ritrovarsi con persone che
riescono a capirsi con le quali vuoi
parlare tranquillamente di determinate
cose senza essere giudicato minimamente
per me il concetto di strano in realtà
nel sesso è veramente tanto limitato
cioè a me piace tanto sperimentare
quando lei racconta io col mio compagno
condividono anche certe passioni certe
curiosità quella cosa io ce l'ho molto
forte devo esser sincero che sono sempre
stato molto fortunato per avere molta
libertà di dialogo su questa cosa e
quindi io non leggo come stranezza e so
se è chiaro il concerto è cioè per me
quella è la naturalezza del sesso avere
delle curiosità corporee che con
rispetto si condividono come una persona
che ti sta a fianco gati che hanno fatto
è capitato mai adesso parlavi di
situazioni dove insomma poco rispettose
di spaventarti sì ho conosciuto un
ragazzo di roma mai visto lui poi c'era
l'opzione di poter comprare il numero di
telefono quindi avevo il mio telefono di
lavoro le persone compravano il numero
di telefono e poi ti volevano scrivere
fuori questo ragazzo mi scriveva tutti i
giorni tutto il giorno e figli tu dici
vabbè ci sta poi arrivato a un certo
punto che inizia a chiedermi vediamoci
vediamoci vediamoci tu mi piaci tu mi
piaci tu mi piaci ho detto guarda non è
cattiveria no
il tipo si è agitato si è arrabbiato lo
bloccato ha iniziato a scrivermi con
altri numeri a chiamarmi quando stavo in
campo e mi scriveva tutto il tempo con
altri profili ho smesso di fare cam
quindi dopo un tot di mesi non l'ho più
sentito me lo sono ritrovato su
instagram dopo instagram l'ho bloccato
mi ha scritto su only fans e lì è
partito tipo una minaccia dicendomi
affidati che prima o poi scoprire dove
stai
e lì son cazzi tuoi ho mai denunciato
cioè no l'ho bloccato e buzz aldrin e
già non l'ho più sentito io sono ci
tengo molto in realtà la denuncia è a
questi strumenti in realtà sono potenti
ma più che altro per preservare le
persone in su temi anche le ragazze che
poi sono sempre quelli che ci rimettono
anche perché ormai sono passati un anno
e mezzo non l'ho più sentito più sentito
poi non so manco più a roma quindi è
molto più sicura frequentare quella
piattaforma sia un uomo odio dipende dai
contenuti che porti anche quello il
fatto cioè io conosco ragazzi che
portano i contenuti dei suoli fans e
purtroppo ricevono un sacco di minacce
cose molto pesanti e brutte stessa cosa
vale per noi ragazze la maggior parte
dei ragazzi che conosco che fanno only
fans come noi nel senso fanno video un
po di tutti i generi poi in realtà non
hanno tutte queste grandi minacce tra
virgolette nel caso di questo mondo è un
mondo che effettivamente ad oggi sta
crescendo nel quale può anche convenire
se investire senza in italiano perché le
tasse di registro non contasse 46 42 43
e c'è la metafora del sismi la metà cioè
più o meno la metà ragazzi è un'azienda
questo vuol dire che la mia azienda
prende meta e la dallo stato e l'altra
metà ha poi la dame della quale meta
dallo status limitava a me quindi alla
fine me arriva un quarto vuol dire che
fatturi tanto però perchè non fai una
vita orribile posso dirvi una cosa
aspetto guadagli ora è quella che l'anno
scorso quasi fattori il nostro primo
milione o minchiate infatti speriamo
bene contiamo così altrimenti
possiamo rifare le stesse puntati di
feroci completamente nudi bello
ragazzi ma non ha capito ma la mia
stella di diamante ok jimmy by si
guarda ti dico la verità io mi trovo
molto più a mio agio nuda rispetto che
te lo giuro su dio lo dico sempre a
tutti perché così se non ci fosse stata
la quarantena
non avessi iniziato questo percorso cosa
avresti fatto penso che avrei cominciato
comunque perché l'idea era proprio
quella a tutta questa idea ce l'avevi da
tanto tenero dall'idea non appena
abbiamo incominciato a
fare queste live allora grande domanda
se non avessi incontrato il tuo ragazzo
non l'avrei fatto non l'avresti fatto
c'era qualcosa che ti interessava che
avesse voluto fare in realtà ero molto
indecisa su quello che volevo fare la
mia vita avevo 18 anni pensavo lì per lì
a lavorare e fare quello che stavo
facendo non avevo una bella situazione a
casa quindi messa un pò accontentando di
quello che mi sento questa cosa comunque
tutto questo vorrei ringraziare gli
autori che mi scrivono ma se vuoi
metterti a tuo agio a nuda guarda che io
dico ma siamo a stiamo scavando nostra
città i suoi semi inesatto veramente
i tuoi seni perché questa è la classica
frase di uno a te
scrive su instagram mobile foto gratis
dei tuoi simili quei caldi se mi posso
dire poeta
[Applauso]
posso fare una domanda io per cui mi
devo togliere gli occhiali addirittura
si arriva a provinare allora visto che
stiamo parlando di
imprevedibilità c'è se noi dovessimo
aprire un canale su ali fans quanto
dovremmo chiedere al mese come ci
dovremmo chiamare
la meritiamo fuori la tua creatività
io con la creatività queste cose 0
ragazzi tutto il mio ragazzo perché io e
ben ali da questo punto di vista proprio
zero io penso che come abbonamento
dovreste chiede intorno ai 40 40 scusa
io devo chiedere 40 come guglielmo hai
ragione
è vergognoso ha visto che tu ci
ammorbare sti cazzo ma guarda io sono
sicuro che il cliente che lei scrive
mostrati semi dio canale sarebbe
felicissimo
tu poi magari poi vende pure qualcosa di
privato no una volta che uno se cioè io
per diversi lato andiamo sul centone
qui non sapeva
bene qui sono di consigli di turisti per
esempio una persona una ragazza un
ragazzo che sta iniziando questa questa
carriera ci vuole tanta calma c'è tanta
pazienza e non si devono far butta giù
dalle malelingue che è sempre pieno e
soprattutto quando ti ritrovi magari ad
arrivare ad un certo livello devi sempre
stare attento delle persone che ti
circondano ed io una domanda ma suoli
fans quindi puoi vedere le chat puoi
vedere le foto in chat anche puoi
vendere foto i video e vocali ma tu
hai focali mettere dei ragazzi ragazzi
avuto un'idea per il mio canale all i
fans non sarebbe un musical
e fai sesso cantando io immagino sto
musical scusami ma il video
insieme capito ci fai proprio sentito la
signora creata io immagino questo
michele bravi in musical
gorgo
sarebbe incredibile che sarebbe una cosa
un sacco innovativo qualcosa che neanche
esiste una cosa del genere ragazzi fallo
sono 30 grazie è stato bello per le
prossime puntate trovatevi un sostituto
al io a volte ho cercato magari nella
pornografia una fuga da quella che era
una relazione morta a livello sessuale
cosa consigli quali potrebbero essere
dei modi anche ragazzi questa quando
quando e fa ciò che vuoi per ravvivare
un pochino la coppia quando le cose non
funzionano
ora io penso che la cosa carina sia tipo
i giochi di ruolo
i giochi di ruolo su top cioè io li
adoro ma tipo quali sono le situazioni
senza medico e paziente che ho provato e
che in piacenza cattivo lui che fa il
ladro e tecnico io ho fatto tribolare
che alla sono innocente
allora che cosa è successo che io stavo
sul divano in salotto dei miei suoceri
quindi lui già sapeva questa cosa è
stata improvvisativa quali si decidono
prima
cioè io stavo sul divano ok con il pc a
un certo punto arriva lui da dietro che
prende una corda mi lega il cat ci aveva
il passamontagna cagata sotto dalla
paura perché giustamente di non arrivi
collegato è lì per lì non ho preso mi
allegata
e poi ha detto non fai quello che ti
dico io oppure succedono cose allora
ma anche un'altra volta ero vestita da
poliziotta avevo comprato perché io
inizialmente non mettevo non ci mettevo
il viso soprattutto nelle gamme perché
ho portato la mia prima maschera
la voglio vedere questa è stata la mia
prima maschera che poi voglio di chi mi
conosce come fanno riconoscere
solo vedere un attimo sovrapposta al tuo
viso aspetta
è un pochino tipo sailor moon che aveva
come una montana da chi cazzo è questa
ma io mettevo questa però con la
parrucca coi capelli non
le lenti a contatto blu e poi ci sono
stati giustamente altre no perché poi
dopo tipo un mese o nozze la mostra il
vino perché mi ero rotta le scatole di
chiuro con frutta occhio però portato
anche un'altra cosa molto bella che
stava è stato il regalo più bello che mi
ha fatto mia suocera
curiosissimi curiosissima
è un sex toy per caso digitale si vuol
dire che vuol dire
che carina c'è pure la cravatta allora
sto chiedendo e scusi posso come
funziona di su allora tu accendi questo
qui il pulsantino per al gender non sono
così a carico perché perché diciamo che
sempre felice eppure io pure mi trovo
con il minipimer sempre scarico eccolo
[Musica]
tanto è super disinfettato giuro
non ci credo se si guarda che ci sono in
frequenza si
scusa continuerei a
dieci più o meno hai pure la modalità
dove lo fai tu triay guai tipo tu la
nuova geniale ma se io purtroppo sui sex
toys veramente l'ignoranza incredibile
ma tu stai scherzando
un mondo che non conosco ma ti permette
invece di scoprire il mondo del tuo
corpo però perché oa perché sono
veramente
micidiali nel senso che crea una
dipendenza
sì perché c'è io inizialmente ho sempre
fatto con le mani da quando su questi
ragazzi non mi regge più la velocità
della mano dopo un po perché eso pigra
c'è questo è certo ok ragazzi so cosa
regalarvi per i vostri compleanni ma
guarda
la boxe cioè con miei proprio saluto o
una boxe l'ho portato anche ma sono
riuscito a vedere questa cosa in bagno
ha detto ma cos'è sta roba lontano una
roba mia poi c'era scritto prox di
volley ne ho spiegato i tuoi propri nei
propri è una roba pesantissima calcolo i
mattoni vibranti sai
ma scusa cosa cosa tiene esattamente qua
dentro
c'è il peso di tutta la tua attività
sessuale è affatto una dentro c'è una
persona
che non me l'aspettavo dopo voglio
assolutamente descritto come una piccola
stanza sartoriale che ci si nasconda
altri solo costruire maschere ragazzi di
conferme segreti voi siete soddisfatti
della vostra vita sessuale allora già
quérelle mita di roma non e non intende
il mio non è un discorso negativo è che
io mi rendo conto che io vorrei forse
che ho una parte di me che potrebbe una
vita sessuale molto dinamica sempre in
evoluzione sempre stimolante e che forse
ha una forma o comunque un piccolo
aspetto che cerca la pole è cola che
cerca quindi l'apertura nei in una
sessualità un pochino meno convenzionale
io devo dire che non ho ancora trovato
secondo me la persona
con cui mi sono sentito proprio libero
di sperimentare lo cento per cento
esatto di quello di sperimentare
qualsiasi cosa cioè tipo non mi verrebbe
da dire facciamo gioco di ruolo facciamo
questo c'è un quest al diciamo che non
hai trovato un quan per ginevra esatto
brava
se il tuo caso se soddisfatto invece
della tua vita sessuale devo dire sì sì
perché ho la fortuna di avere dei
partner a fianco in passato attuali è
che la mia seconda non molto
soddisfacente che si comunque c'è questa
cosa del dialogo si apre sempre in
maniera molto naturale
tutte le volte in cui non sia aperto si
è trattata di un'occasione perché non è
un qualcosa che io riesco a portare
avanti e quindi il fatto che riesco
sempre a dialogare con le persone con
cui non magari un rapporto diretto sei
soddisfatto della tua vita si sono
solitamente si c'è qualcosa che vuoi
aggiungere prima di salutarci ci siamo
veramente detti di
siri e mi farà una bella risata pensa
ripensando tutto quello che ci siamo
detti salutaci quando mi raccomando mai
è un membro importante ma non volevo
utilizzare quella parola membro
competente componente un componente
portante questa chiacchiera grazie aver
operato disputerà
possiamo fare la chiusura come fosse un
gioco di ruolo io voglio essere una
signora con i bigodini in testa che
appena tornata dal supermercato io
voglio essere un membro della curia
romana 75enne io voglio essere la
radical chic
guarda i
ragazzi sentite siamo stanchi questa è
questa qui è una chiacchiera che ci ha
fatto insomma riflettere tanto molto è
venuta una voglia disco
vi saluto al volo perché devo andare a
procacciare un po vampiro la mia
prossima vittima che dire siamo giunti
quindi alla fine di questa seconda
puntata di feroci se l'avete ritenuta
troppo spinta o scottante sappiate che
il meglio deve ancora venire nella
prossima comprata infatti abbiamo deciso
di andare ancora più a fondo molto più a
fondo all'interno di un organo che
indipendentemente dalle dimensioni può
dare molto piacere bisogna saperle usare
bisogna saperlo proteggere ma
soprattutto è quanto di più intimo noi
possediamo sto parlando del cervello da
noi c'e roncetti
ragazzi e le ragazze un graffio mia oh
[Musica]